are women really that smart
they are then why don't we have a female
Elon Musk
they're smart
but that's it okay
okay he just throws it away
so so for me it's not that smart okay so
what do women do that's so smart
do things
do you know what I mean I was like what
are we doing that's so smart nowadays
[Music]
men or women can do but but I think you
you think more we think more do we think
better
I think we think worse
yeah look around do you see all the
girls dressed like hookers
is that smart yeah yeah
is the first
person
okay
well it was just defense I was just
thinking like what's smarter
dressing like a hooker or getting
married to a rich man
neither neither exactly neither
um you know build your career and you've
got a breakdowns when you go to go
hiring the business or build your own
business
but but women aren't doing that like we
talked about Elon Musk and the women
that build their own businesses are
hookers like Kim Kardashian
and Kylie Jenner
yeah
but men are doing the hard way right
who you know who I know yeah okay
okay but you still think women are
smarter than men
oh you think we're equal I think the men
are smarter
we didn't even say so well thank you
guys very much very good sport